hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where
it has been a week just
emotionally overwhelming and exhausting
and um
terrible and and positive at the same
time
and you know sometimes you just have a
week but i am also a person
who um while i feel like i talk about
negative things that happen on the
internet i also try to talk about
positive things that happen on the
internet and just be very real
so um i suspect that something
very exciting has happened today i don't
know yet
i've avoided it um but
i think so when i went to sleep last
night i had 499
913 subscribers here on youtube
even getting to that many since my first
video in
2012 was previously incomprehensible to
me
um it's now what time is it
it's 4 20 p.m hashtag blaze it and
i suspect that i probably have 500 000
subscribers
on youtube um
which
i feel like i shouldn't celebrate it
when i haven't even looked at it but i'm
like wow it's amazing i haven't even i
don't even know like
this could only be like [ __ ] so
let's open her up shall we
got your uh display capture up here
shout out to pixlr it's the website i
used to make all my thumbnails
excellent editing service for those who
don't use photoshop
it's like i'm rambling because i'm
nervous to see this thing that is
ultimately incredible news it's gonna
change my size because i feel like it's
gonna be about like here on the screen
i think okay
uh
i uh
yep look 500 000 subscribers is nothing
you know um i recognize that
in the grand scheme of youtube like
that's such a small number um
and i've been making youtube videos
since 2012. like this isn't something
that happened quickly
it's it's a really long time
um and a very slow growth and
uh i'm not trying to
to act like this is you know
the most amazing accomplishment in the
world but
i'm very proud of my youtube community
i have had a period of like
three years where i wasn't even allowed
to talk about video games because ign
didn't let me while i was working there
and it is something that i've always
treated as as
a hobby um you know youtube's not my job
it has always been
the place where i just am very genuine
um i'm really just very much myself
and um as a result of that i think that
i i never
expected this channel to hit a million
subscribers or or even 500 000 or even a
hundred thousand
you know this [ __ ] paused face has
been here this whole time while i'm
saying all this emotional [ __ ]
let's just can we just cover that alana
you [ __ ] okay let's just
all right let's just do this shall we
there we go it's gone
i just um i think i needed something
positive today
and uh this is definitely something that
that
i've been excited about because it's a
milestone and and again i'm really proud
of my youtube community i've never made
any content
that i didn't want to make or anything
that um i did for views or
anything that was forced it's it's all
been very genuine and very
myself and very um
i don't know just
to the people who've joined me on this
journey
i've been a lot of hard work i put a lot
of hours into this kind of thing
and my youtube community is [ __ ]
awesome
it really is i've worked professionally
for several youtube channels and
fight is absolutely the best
not in terms of you know the content i
make my content is frequently
unprofessional
but um in terms of my community and uh
i just want to say thank you like i've
been uploading more over the last
several months because i've been
self-isolating so i've been in my
apartment
alone since march
may since may and that's been really
tough it's tough
you know i don't i don't go outside
because i'm
high risk and um there's a pandemic that
affects those with respiratory illnesses
like this guy
so i've been working on this channel
more in my spare time as like
something that's kept me sane and uh
it's been very awesome to be able to do
that
and very helpful to have people to make
and discuss
things with about video games um i'm so
proud of my podcast
and and the wonderful people that i get
to make that with and the community who
tolerates our
stupid tangents and i also just wanted
to say
i've done a lot of charity live streams
this year um
i'm trying to put good energy into the
world where i can and i recognize that
that means i am repeatedly asking people
to donate money to these causes
and every time my community blows the
goals out of the water and i
i no one no one gets mad when i ask
again in another another two weeks or
whatever you know it's just
i don't even know what to say um numbers
shouldn't matter
of course but this took so
long and i think is an accomplishment
that even though
my own brain just wants me to downplay
it because i'm like it's tiny
all my friends have bigger youtube
channels i work for bigger youtube
channels it's still um
i am proud of the community i felt i
really am
thank you i think it's also just
i started this channel to learn to edit
and to be more comfortable on camera
because i am at my core a writer i don't
think i've ever been
a good camera personality i don't i
don't think i ever have
i know i'm low energy and always tired
and i know all those things
and i have no interest in changing them
and and um certainly nobody on this
channel has ever asked me to
even if like every reaction video
comments are always why doesn't she
react though what the [ __ ]
why i just don't have anything to fake
it um but i started this channel to like
to learn and get better and get more
comfortable because it's really bad when
i started
um and to edit and to you know help
my my career which has brought me all
the way from australia to the us
to work in an industry i love with a lot
of people i really love
um who've been wonderful to me
throughout
you know the past five years where i
have lived here away from every person
i've ever known and my entire family and
um
certainly a lot of it started here
and there are people on this channel who
followed me from
the days where i ran a tumblr where i
just blogged about video games
a lot when i was i don't know 14 maybe
to writing from magazines in australia
and then
you know working on community tv and
radio and writing for websites and then
ign
and now fun house
and um
i'm gonna hate editing this video
because i'm gonna be like this is
pathetic what are you [ __ ] doing you
idiot but it's just been a very
emotional week okay
i think i uh
i always feel like you know any number
growing on any of my social media is
just always makes me feel like i just
need to keep doing more good
um try to help more people
and and i think the community i have
reflects that and i have some
more cool sort of charity related stuff
coming up that i'm really excited to
to announce that i um hope you'll all
join me on
and i don't know sometimes i feel like
i'm asking too much
whatever this is rambly just thank you
thank you for
helping me and i guess i just also want
to say
to the alana that that
started this career in
2011 started this channel in 2012.
[ __ ] yeah dude you've dealt with a lot
of [ __ ]
and um the internet can be awful but i
even just mean like some shitty people
professionally
and uh
nothing nothing defeated you little
alana and that's [ __ ] awesome
and also massively thanks to
um an incredible community
i hate this i hate this
[ __ ] all right it's just 500 it's not
even
i mean thinking about that amount of
people in a room is insane but i try not
to focus on the numbers and i know that
it's small and i just
okay just
thank you all so much thank you